bonjour je suis libre et j'ai dadan j'ai
51 ans je suis denise yen depuis depuis
51 ans alors je suis conseillère
départementale et je suis dans la
commission solidarités et cohésion
sociale
quand on
de s'adonner 3 est un grand compte en
qui regroupe à peu près trente neuf
mille habitants et c'est un canton qui
est hétérogène puisqu'on a des cartes
sécuritaire des quartiers résidentiels
des quartiers urbanisés des quartiers
ruraux nous sommes dans un quartier dans
un grand canton qui regroupe beaucoup de
familles en difficulté une population
qui est vieillissante également ce qui
est moi je suis attaché à se rendre
d'abord parce que j'ai grandi aux
camélias et et ma maman il habite
toujours j'ai dans mon parcours
politique
j'étais sur le projet de rénovation
urbaine des camélias également donc
voilà donc je suis élu à montgaillard ce
qui veut dire aussi que c'est un canton
que je connais très très bien et les
gens au quotidien m'ont beaucoup inspiré
dans mon engagement politique les
citoyens a montré qu'il y avait une
nécessité en tout cas faire en sorte que
les choses évoluent et moi je veux
contribuer à cette évolution je veux
participer à cette construction d'un
saint denis aux formes un canton
dynamique
alors pour moi les premières actions
comme j'existe tout à l'heure c'est
ramener de la proximité des services
dans nos quartiers tout simplement pour
redonner du sens à l'action politique du
département dans nos quartiers parce que
nous avons des familles en grande
souffrance qui ont du mal à partir loin
de leur quartier soit au bas de la
rivière soit ici au bas de la source
c'est très compliqué et une fois les
gens n'ont pas un euro 30 pour descendre
bas de la rivière je veux voudrait
ramener l'action sociale au coeur du
quartier ça c'est une priorité ensuite
deuxième axe c'est le handicap s'est
redonné toute la place aux personnes
porteuses handicap aux enfants
handicapés parce
il ya aujourd'hui une déficience dans
nos services
ralentir 20 accélérée par dont le délai
de traitement des dossiers pour ces
personnes-là le dossier d'un dps ne peut
pas prendre six mois un an des fois deux
ans pour contribuer à l'amélioration de
l'habitat par exemple pour faire un
dossier parce que quelqu'un est en
grande souffrance donc il faut vraiment
accélérer ce procès ce dernier rate
aujourd'hui moi me sens important c'est
notre jeunesse c'est dans le collège
c'est je voudrais vraiment qu'on arrive
à travers le volet culturel traiter des
sujets importants comme les addictions
jeu
l'addiction à l'alcool la prévention sur
la grossesse précoce des sujets qui sont
fondamentaux mais qui peuvent se traiter
à travers la culture à travers une quasi
théâtre à travers l'art urbain à travers
le chant à travers la musique donc tout
ça me permet vraiment aujourd'hui de
dire qu'on a les outils pour faire alors
faisons ensemble
alors je pense que le département peut
aider dans l'avenir en se rapprochant du
citoyen en étant vraiment de proximité
revenir dans nos quartiers c'est ça
l'essence même du politique c'est bien
le sens que je veux donner à l'action
politique l'action publique doit
réinvestir les quartiers